we have to talk about something that we
were really excited about
yesterday and we didn't get to it and
this is my top priority story all right
this is coming out of los angeles
according to wired the city is trying
out a new way of building roads and
instead of using tar
to bind road asphalt together the city
will be using recycled
plastic waste yes no this is the stuff i
need this process makes the road last
twice as long and if it works it could
find a use
for all the world's plastic waste like a
hundred percent of it
game game changers and similar programs
are being done
in switzerland and indonesia india
and thailand ross i know i just want to
repeat what you said in there that makes
the roads like
the cement roads they have now last
twice as long
yes right it's it's more durable than
what we have it's smarter than what we
have
this is what we need who forget about
miles per hour let's recycle by hour
also they're testing out if like when
the cars go if like it puts particles of
plastic in the air they're doing lots of
testing it's not
perfected yet but we are on the road pun
intended
to what i need to hear
you know there's good news on a vaccine
um
this is good news i worry about you know
what we're doing to ourselves on this
planet
and when i see something like this i
think innovation
technology saving ourselves loving our
planet
putting investing into our future this
is the kind of stuff i need to know
about because this is where i see
humanity
shine at its best this is not gluttony
and selfishness
this is problem solving innovation and
leadership on a level where we are
taking what we naturally do
which isn't natural and turning it into
something good this is the function we
need
smart people are doing smart things we
may just be okay drew
vaccine and plastic recycled bottle
roads okay let's get right
to our next guest i've been dying to
talk to them obsessed since i saw i know
i saw this clip i couldn't believe it
when i saw it okay he's wrestling a
gator
for starters and i mean how often do you
get to say that i hope i never have to
say that in a weird way but let him go
look at him go
and he's joining us now from estero
florida please welcome rick wilbank
hi rick good morning good morning
oh and there is gunner your doggy dog
i am so excited to meet you we'll get
into the rescue in a second but
how did you keep the cigar in your mouth
the whole time yeah did you watch that
the whole time
uh well you just have to have a cigar
and
and then uh if gator grabs your puppy
you just gotta
pry his jaws open and snatch the puppy
out
oh my god so i have little dogs and when
i saw this i have to tell you i thought
i don't know if i could have done that
but was it just this instinctual thing
was there fear there or did you just go
for it
because the gator oh i just went for it
it was just reaction it happened so fast
and
then i saw the alligator just swimming
off with gunner in his mouth and i just
jumped right in the water and
got my hands on the alligator and got
him up on the bank
and you surprised your wife with uh
gunner right you you found him you saw
him you met him and you were
are you found this puppy and you were
like i gotta bring him home
yes she was in texas when i got gunner
and she
got home to a surprise i have to say
can we try to reenact this ross because
okay or like we're going to put the dogs
in a book
is the book the gator yeah the book is
the gator with the jaws of life
of course you know rick you dealt with
the real thing
oh about is how i was sort of watching
out getting the dog out and then you
jump in the pond
hold the gator's mouth open right yes
sir
uh-huh i just have to say rick i think
you're like
the coolest dude ever and we're all
marveling at you and you're all over
social media
this has totally gone viral and
rightfully so because not
only do you do what we wonder what would
happen
in that moment and we hope we'd be like
you just get it done
but the fact that you didn't break
character the whole time
is like another level of cool
well thank you so much thank you but you
know
you look at this beautiful little puppy
and anybody would have jumped in after
him
yeah well rick you are our hero and
thank you so much and we honor you here
at this show thank you for coming on
and most importantly gunner's okay right
thank you for having me yes thank you
yeah great this gun is great
is doing wonders
thank you rick thank you gunner
[Music]